un face-à-face etats unis russie
probablement sur la crise ukrainienne le
10 janvier prochain des pourparlers qui
devraient se tenir dans le cadre du
dialogue stratégique de sécurité qui a
été lancé lors du dernier sommet de
genève elle les deux puissances
devraient évoquer également les
questions du contrôle de l'armement
nucléaire hier le patron de l'otan a
également invité la russie à discuter le
12 janvier prochain envoyez les
précisions de notre correspondante à
moscou vera goffman
l'avenir des pourparlers entre la russie
et l'alliance atlantique reste incertain
pas de date définitive concernant des
discussions entre la russie et le temps
au sujet des garanties de sécurité
mutuelle a ainsi déclaré le vice
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
sergueï riabkov
plutôt des informations avaient filtré
sur une éventuelle rencontre russie
etats unis le 10 janvier et russie otan
le 12 janvier moscou attend encore des
confirmations de la part de le temps aux
sujets de composition de la délégation
et insiste également sur le fait que
l'agenda ne devienne pas je cite une
abstraction mais se concentre sur les
propositions russes de sécurité mutuelle
je vous propose d'écouter il est
extrêmement important pour nous de
recevoir la confirmation de la part de
l'otan que des militaires de haut rang
seront inclus dans ces délégations lors
de l'événement du tous janvier à
bruxelles nous nous y rendons dans un
format interministériel et notre
ministère de la défense sera représenté
à un niveau très élevé et il est
important pour nous que les militaires
est une conversation professionnels
moscou envisage différentes manières de
répondre aux intimidations de le temps
mais espère passer par la voie
diplomatique avait déclaré dimanche
vladimir poutine des points essentiels
pour éviter le déploiement de l'otan
vers l'est ainsi qu'un engagement de
l'alliance atlantique à ne pas
construire de bases militaires dans des
états de l'ex-bloc soviétique comme en
ukraine